if you do hold out for things if you if
you really stick to your principles
I mean you can't always do that it's
impossible in this industry but if you
try and be like
pretty stubborn with your principles I
think it pays off you know
[Music]
I don't know sometimes you feel like a
total waste of space really when you're
stuck at people with proper jobs and
then you know what the what am I doing
I remember when I was younger I was
really disappointed that I had such a
normal upbringing and I was like I wish
I had a terrible abuse or something that
I could draw on I think that's a lot of
bollocks actually I think it's it's what
you have inside how you're able to be
creative it didn't even come from a
place of pain it didn't come from a
place of sorrow or
you know it just comes from the need to
perform you're just compelled to do it
you know I just love stories I love
interesting characters I love people
behaving in a strange way I love when
you go fine is that person behaving like
that so transgression is much more
interesting than somebody who does the
right thing all the time as an audience
member I I find that much more
interesting
on the real drama kicks in when the
stakes are raised which to me you know
that is real drama when mistakes become
about kind of life and death you're
fully invested in these characters
people need to go to the pictures and
people need some sort of Escape
artists don't let people down like
politicians let people know Bankers let
people down follow you to work by
fluctuate but they keep making it we
keep trying and they keep giving some
sort of Sucker I think you know I
foolishly decided to pursue a law degree
but I was playing music I was playing in
a band and I just started acting then
those two things were happening they
became much more important than going to
college I didn't really go in at all and
I failed gloriously in the first year if
you ever were cruising in your career
and felt sort of confident in everything
that you did that there would be no
Challenge and
and no excitement and no danger it has
to feel a little dangerous I think
you'll have to feel
certainly at the beginning I don't know
if I can do this and then you go at it
and that drives it that that gives you
the hunger and the energy to to go at it
I feel I've been lucky in that I've
moved always between theater television
and movies so if one Avenue got a little
clogged at one point I could just jump
into another Avenue and right I probably
have done that in the past and I think
it I've always felt that if anyone would
say to any artist we love that can you
do it again right which is you know that
happens not not just in our business but
it happens if any time there's a
potential something being commodified or
I've been repeated I think the artists
or the creative person can the other
direction and yeah but luckily I would
always jump from one to the other so
I've never I've never felt that way and
recollaborating with people is always
really good for your creative Soul like
yeah you know I wonder about back in the
70s like when people came in to see a
movie just totally yeah uh and it was
like a fresh experience it must have
been very very exciting but nowadays
everybody's just blogging about
everything so you're kind of expecting
stuff nowadays which is a bit of a shame
I think I guess I'm interested in
duology I'm interested in contradiction
I'm interested in light and shade I'm
interested in the kind of in-between
things of human behavior and you know
villains or Heroes don't really interest
me it's that that world's in between and
I think we're in a good time for telling
stories about characters like that I
think people look for one to
three-dimensional characters in in
either film or television and because
none of us are simple and
straightforward all of us I complicated
I think
people identify with characters that
even though they may be heightened
certainly and people are extremely
heightened but yet it is a story about
the family and people connect to that so
yeah complexity is essential and
storytelling I think if your job is to
portray something truthfully and
honestly then if it's happening in front
of your eyes it helps you enormously and
it's a big Advantage so uh you know when
The Spits fires are flying over for real
and the water is on fire and the
Destroyer is tipping and it's all
happening around you of course you're
heading towards a more truthful response
you know so it helps also I think it
also helps the viewer is there anything
you ever find hard to understand about
Tommy or that you've struggle with with
how to play a certain aspect of Tommy's
character you can't play a character no
matter how far away he is from you
without
you know bringing something of yourself
to it and the more you play it then I
suppose the more part of you he becomes
he never seems to sleep he never seems
to eat that's a Relentless Drive is
really hard here you have to understand
that it's he's formed by his experiences
you know and he's a leader of men or
there may be somebody that can just
you know grab them by the ears and go
you're gonna be you're going to be all
right let's let's you're going to be
okay
I think the unafraid thing is is quite
powerful that you know unafraid to die
or accepting of death due to the to what
he witnessed in the in the first World
War uh and you know has he has seen
things that you know no man should
should see and live with and they all
experienced trauma like that and now we
have a name for you know PTSD but um so
yeah unafraid and I think he doesn't see
a ceiling on what you can achieve in
life because he knows that it can be
snapped out at any moment when you're
acting it shouldn't really be any
past or future there should just be the
present moment and full awareness you
know of what's happening in that present
moment so I tend not to
intellectualize anything at that stage
it has to be purely Instinct actors do
get treated um you're used to being in a
kind of a bubble when I work I work very
intensely and I get get very heavily
involved in it and it's quite immersive
and but then when I don't work
I don't work at all for quite a long
time
as long as I can keep it going
and then and then I go back into it
really intensely I couldn't work
continuously I couldn't go job to job I
don't have the capacity or the stamina
creatively to do that I need to rest
after a job
sort of fall back in love with it again
because I'm always exhausted after work
I'm like yeah that's this and my house
to me alone
and you know I think an actor is quite
again as you guys know it's like if
you're not careful it's quite
infantilizing you know because you're
like so I need a break from it because
it is uh it's a strange world and it's
not real and I and I love it that's why
having a family is so important because
they they will always let you know about
what real life is and also if you're
going to represent
the average person then you gotta live
as best you can as an average person I'm
always very conscious of that and just
want to kind of live as decent to life
off screen as I can you know